back in 1964 the FBI anonymously sent
Martin Luther King jr. what's now known
as a suicide letter some say it was
encouraging Martin Luther King to kill
himself others say well I wasn't really
encouraging him to kill himself but more
encouraging him to maybe decline the
Nobel Peace Prize or maybe to just pull
back his public profile and that letter
is now public its public and mostly
unredacted and we're actually showing it
to people who are watching along with us
you can find it online very very easily
and along with this letter the FBI sent
Martin Luther King a tape recording of
supposed sexual indiscretions and that
was sent both to Martin Luther King and
a little earlier to his wife Coretta
Scott King and that letter eventually
became part of a much bigger scandal
involving the FBI which we don't have to
talk about today in detail but it's
interesting to learn about and is widely
documented at this point this gets me to
yesterday when a Republican congressman
named Brad Wenstrup went on Fox News and
equated the investigation by FBI special
prosecutor Robert Muller right now to
what the FBI did to Martin Luther King
in the 1960s by allegedly apparently
encouraging him to maybe commit suicide
it's almost beyond coherence but I'm
gonna play the audio and video for you
simply to get it on the record in the
set so that we can all have the same
information to then discuss right now I
want us to do our job with what our
government set up for us to do we have
oversight over these agencies if we turn
that around and they feel that they
don't have to answer to the American
people that is a basic problem and a
tenant look the types of things that
we're hearing about now if it was wrong
when they did to Martin Luther King and
it's wrong if they do it to the Trump
campaign and we have the responsibility
and the authority to have oversight over
these things and the American public are
starting to get it and they're tired of
the stalling and the excuses coming from
the Department of Justice and the FBI
and frankly so are we so the FBI has
since admitted that the behavior with
the Martin Luther King thing was
shameful right but there's nothing even
alleged right now in any serious way
aside from the wild conspiracy theories
of the right that would make it similar
to what took place with Martin Luther
King in the 1960s the FBI investigation
by special prosecutor Robert Muller
bears no similarity to what happened
with Martin Luther King the allegations
of impropriety by the DOJ and FBI about
supposed spies from Obama in the Trump
campaign made the the idea that this is
anything other than a smear campaign
meant to confuse people who don't even
really know what the FBI Martin Luther
King story is is absolutely laughable
and what the idea is really is to make
Trump the victim right rather than Trump
being the possible criminal perpetrator
which he is in which he's being
investigated for the idea is to put
Trump in the position of the victim he's
the guy who's being unfairly targeted by
Republicans like James Comey and Robert
Muller
he's the guy who was spied on during his
campaign he's the guy whose personal
lawyer is being railroaded by these
unfair raids at his office and his condo
in his hotel room or whatever and what's
happening here is that all the
Republican conspiracies about this huge
concerted FBI effort to take down Trump
one which again would be mostly carried
out by Republicans like Comey and Robert
Moeller the stories are falling
completely flat with everybody but the
most committed and extreme trumpets so
now people like congressman Wenstrup are
going for this very weak form of ad
hominem they say the FBI is doing the
same thing now to trump that they did to
Martin Luther King in 1964 and this
Wenstrup guy is the same congressman who
said back when hope Hicks admitted to
lying for Donald Trump it's no big deal
that she's lying because they were all
white lies and there's no more reason
whatsoever to look at a an official from
the White House admitting to lying on
the behalf of the President of the
United States
they're throwing anything they can think
of at the wall to see what sticks and
this is just the latest and this of
course says nothing about the absurdity
of even equating Trump to Martin Luther
King in
anyway right I mean like so the number
one thing is there's nothing about what
the FBI is doing now that's similar to
what the FBI did to Martin Luther King
but deep down in that analogy on some
level there's the idea that in some way
Trump is a figure that is someway
equatable to who Martin Luther King was
I don't feel that I really need to
discuss that any further but certainly
nothing there as well but but that that
the idea that someone would even have
the audacity to show up on Fox News and
do this is stunning and it's actually
stunning at this point that I'm even
stunned that they're willing to do this
right they've been willing to do
everything as the pressure continues to
mount why am I even surprised that
they're also willing to go out and say
that this is like when the FBI
encouraged Martin Luther King to Kin
kill himself
investigating corrupt actions by
government actors is nothing like
telling a civil rights leader to kill
themselves the video you just watched
was made possible by support from you
please go to patreon.com slash david
pakman show you can make a pledge of as
little as $1 per month and every dollar
helps to support the work that we're
doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad